Film Courage: What came first for you, art
or business?
Dale Stelly, Filmmaker: It was…it was both
actually.
They came at the same time.
I was fortunate to have a very close friend
of mine Daniel Zirilli that I did my first
production job with and I was craft service
or something in like 1995?
My first job on set was craft service and
was for a very good friend of mine Daniel
Zirilli (he owns the company called Pop Art
Film Factory).
What I learned from him right off the bat
was he was a director.
Not only was he a director, but he owned the
production company.
So I learned right off the bat if I wanted
to be in this game, I had to be like my friend
Daniel.
I’ve got to own the company, I’ve got
to own the production company and then direct.
So I learned the business before directing
like you have to set up a company.
I set up Stelly Entertainment.
I PA’d and then I Second AD’d, then First
AD’d 1995 into 1996 and working behind my
friend Daniel being 21 at the time I got envious
of him.
I’m like “Man, I want to be a director.”
He was older than me and obviously like a
mentor in a way but he didn’t realize that
I was actually paying attention and sucking
up everything.
And so after 1996 I developed this attitude
of like “I want to be a director.”
So I’m 21 or 22 talking about I want to
be a music video director.
I was working at Kodak at the time and being
in the shadow of my friend Daniel Zirilli
and him kind of bringing me up the ranks like
PA, Second AD to First AD.
I was first ADing music videos that were on
BET in like 1996 and that’s what kind of
built up my confidence to start Stelly Entertainment
from a business perspective because if people
are going to take me seriously I’ve got
to have a production company and then my production
company will loan out my directing services
or my writing services or my producing services
or whatever.
So in my 20’s I learned right away how to
run a production company to get checks written
to Stelly Entertainment not to Dale Stelly.
That was a big deal for me and a big step
for me and my company because I worked at
a post house at the time and I would take
some of my friends out to lunch and then when
I would put my credit card down it was my
Stelly Entertainment credit card and they’d
be like “How do you have a Stelly Entertainment
credit card?”
And I was already starting my business, I
was already doing lunches.
It was bananas because I had already foreseen
me starting my company, I already seen my
taking my friends out on lunch meetings.
I had already seen myself buying this car,
seeing my car going on the back lot with my
“Director” plates.
I visualized all of this and I made it happen
and in like 2006 or 2007 I am going on the
back lot of Universal.
They are letting me in because they know my
car and recognize me.
Everything I pre-visualized and everything
came to life all the way to me getting an
office on the back lot not even knowing how
that was going to happen but I knew “I want
to be on the back lot.”
And I ended up on the back lot for like a
year and a half with a partner of mine.
But yes, when you believe and you have faith
and you put that in the Universe everyday
you can manifest some unbelievable situations.
And I like to say me I don’t come from a
rich family.
I just really dedicated myself in figuring
out this movie business, every facet, from
post production, I worked in post production
for over 13 years so I know exactly what it
takes to shoot and make a movie for little
money or for huge amounts of money.
And having that talent and skill is very valuable
in this business.
Because right now with the technology and
everything people are condensing film crews
to three man, four man.
And it used to be 25 people crew back in the
day because of the budgets and technologies,
these millennials they done figured out how
to make projects on cell phones and everything.
So it’s like you really have got to stay
on top of the creativity and put out the best
product that you can economically and you’ll
win.